i fell in love with mathematics at
school when my teacher explained to me
that what this subject is all about is
actually something he liked to call the
art of the shortcut
so what i wanted to do was to give you
this perspective that my teacher gave me
about why mathematics is so amazing
because it's basically
the best collection of shortcuts that
we've gathered over our kind of two
thousand three thousand years of
exploring mathematics
i think another reason i fell in love
with maths is because i loved solving
puzzles uh the idea of having a puzzle
and there's clearly a very stupid way to
do puzzles quite often
but the real joy is
finding that clever way of thinking
about the problem what i call the
shortcut and then the whole thing just
falls apart and you go oh that's
so i understand this now
so here's the little puzzle and and
maybe we'll solve this at the the end of
uh the video so you're a grosser and
you've got one of those um scales
balance scales so you can put things on
either side and you want to be able to
weigh things from one kilogram up to 40
kilograms just whole number units what
is the smallest number of weights
you can get away with so you know what's
the shortcut for the grocer in not
having to buy you know weights from 1 to
40. that's obviously you could do 40.
but what is the smallest number you can
get away with
so we have to be able to cover every
integer presumably not not not 0.7 no i
don't want 0.7 so i just you want from 1
2 3 all the way up to 40.
and so remember you can put weights on
either side you're going to be using
that fact to sort of cut down uh the
number you need actually the problem
that caught my imagination when i was at
school and it's a problem uh you've
probably done a number file on it that
moment when gauss at school was asked to
add the numbers up from one to a hundred
and the story goes is the teacher who
challenged the class with this problem
was hoping to get a little bit of rest
because he knew this would take a long
time one plus two plus three and sure
enough all the other students started
doing their arithmetic but almost before
the teacher could finish with a
challenge gauss had put down his
blackboard with the answer on you know
how did he manage to find a shortcut to
doing this huge amount of work of adding
up numbers
and you know the lovely shortcut is he
spotted a pattern which is if you add
the numbers one plus a hundred two plus
ninety nine three plus ninety eight
they're all 101 and you've got 50 of
these pairs and so you've just got 50
lots of 101 5050. and i think this
beautifully illustrated for me the power
of mathematical thought as a shortcut
first of all you you've just cut out
just having to do a huge slog of hard
work
one up to a hundred but the beauty of
this shortcut again is that it it works
however big the number if the teacher
had said count up to a million the same
trick works and i think for me that was
just so exciting i think it sort of
appealed to me as a lady teenager that i
didn't want to do a lot of hard work
the idea of learning this
kind of skill set of shortcuts um
and that's actually what i've been
doing over uh the last few months is
sort of gathering in a book uh the idea
of different shortcuts that we have in
mathematics and i think one of them is
pattern searching which is the one that
gauss was using
but there's a kind of funny paradox here
because although i think i actually was
drawn to shortcuts
because i was a bit lazy at school and i
like the idea that if i thought cleverly
i could get through to the answer really
quickly and then i could go and play
football
actually in my professional life as a
mathematician
finding shortcuts finding those
shortcuts can take a very long time
so you're kind of stuck in front of this
wall you just don't know what to do but
that's actually the joy and it taps into
that idea of a puzzle the best puzzles
are the one that you wrestle with for
ages and then
you get it so
i think the shortcuts that we've come up
with
throughout the history of mathematics
one has to remember that
mathematicians have spent a long time
coming up with these shortcuts that now
we teach at school and university we've
made the tunnel through the mountain um
and that's what i hope you know we we
communicate but i think it's a sort of
new perspective i don't think people
think of um
uh mathematics as kind of like the art
of the shortcut i imagine a lot of the
things i learned at high school when i
was learning mathematics
that are considered you know the tools
of mathematics are in fact shortcuts
they've just become so standardized that
we just think that's what mathematics is
yes i mean so i think you know algebra
is a shortcut to not having to do
individual calculations on each numbers
it's spotting the underlying pattern but
i think some of my favorite shortcuts
ones we've made number files about but
one of my favorite is euler's kind of
solution to why the bridges of
konigsberg can't be uh crossed so you
know we're all brought up on this story
as a kind of mathematical fairy tale the
seven bridges crossing the river pregal
the residents in kurnicksburg sunday
afternoon they try and cross it and
again here's the hard work how would you
show that you can't cross these well
you've got to do all the possibilities
that's going to take forever well not
forever but a long time the beauty of
euler's shortcut is once he's drawn the
network and understood that each node in
this network of bridges there can be
either zero or two places with an odd
number of bridges coming out if there
are two that's the beginning and the end
of the journey but everywhere else
you're going in and out on different
bridges so you've got an even number
that's inspired because you know now i
can draw an incredibly complicated
network but using this shortcut all i
need to do is to count the number of
vertices with odd number bridges coming
out of it and i know whether it is
navigable or not and there's an issue i
mean brady you you live near bristol so
um uh you got a lot of bridges around
bristol and in fact somebody's analyzed
um i think it's in the region like 40 50
bridges now that's quite complicated
network but he was able to spot
using this euler shortcut okay this is
possible and so he actually did it i
think it took over a day to travel all
of these bridges but he knew at the
outset that he'd be he'd be able to do
it there's a nice little coder to this
story because i actually went to
kernigsburg it's now called kaliningrad
it's a small little enclave or exclave i
think it's because it's separate from
russia surrounded by other countries but
i actually discovered there are still
seven bridges but they're arranged in a
completely different configuration
there's a railway bridge you can cross
there's a dual carriageway if you draw
the diagram now there are two places
where an odd number of bridges come in
and out so when i went to kaliningrad i
actually walked the seven bridges of
kaliningrad although the shortcut told
me i'd never be able to do the ones at
kearneysburg are there lots of tourists
they're doing that is that a thing you
do there or is that was it just two or
three mathematicians a month for i i
think that i was probably the only one
uh on that day scammering around
kaliningrad which is quite a grim city
actually um but i loved it it was like
visiting mathematical disneyland
professor when you when a big new proof
comes out for mars last theorem or some
of the big ones
is a common thread through those things
that that the genius discovered a
shortcut or sometimes is the way to a
proof there was no shortcut you had to
you know really push through
this is a really interesting question
because it came up in my analysis of
this sort of sometimes actually you need
to take a detour to sort of find your
way through and sometimes that detour
will be as exciting as the shortcut and
i don't think fermat's last theorem had
we found something that could fit in the
margin
of course it wouldn't have had the same
kind of value to us
that it has today because it was such a
grand challenge but on the other hand if
you look at that journey a long journey
that was made over 350 years absolutely
there are moments of shortcuts where
suddenly you realize oh i found a
passage from this equation of fermat's
through to completely different land
that you know the modular forms uh now i
have to understand something about
elliptic curves and modular forms that
was the ultimate shortcut because it was
almost like finding a tunnel to a
completely different area and i think in
in my research that's often what i'm
looking for is those sneaky tunnels
which take me from a problem coached in
one sort of language and then turning it
into something else where actually
there's the tools to answer the problem
is there a danger to shortcuts if you do
they become a crutch and if you always
take the shortcut could you miss that
thing that no one had seen before well
for me i think the danger of shortcuts
is when does it become cutting corners
and i think this is a real uh this is a
real
challenge because very often in
mathematics what we try and do is throw
away information which isn't important
you know it wasn't important the
geometry of kernigsberg what was
important was the the way it was
connected together and um you know one
of the powerful shortcuts we come out
with not just in mathematics but also
across the sciences is the power of a
diagram if you think about physicists
and chemists their their blackboards are
covered in all these strange little
letters with lines coming out of them
that's a molecule but um it's a diagram
of a molecule the dna spiral you
couldn't put all the detail of the dna
but they they they crystallized what was
important about this
double helix so i think
that is a really powerful one and again
in a way
networks are tapping into topology is
about connectivity london underground
map is not a physical map you've thrown
away things the challenge is making sure
you don't throw away too much um and
that's i think interesting when it comes
to our incredibly data rich world um how
do we navigate through this incredible
jungle of numbers and again mathematics
has come up with some extraordinary
shortcuts to to find our way through
understanding what is happening in those
numbers but again you need to be careful
there's a chance that you might have
missed some signal inside of there there
was this advert when i was a kid um
about cat food whiskers cat food and it
it kind of said very grandly eight out
of ten cats prefer whiskers and and we
had a cat and i don't remember anybody
ever coming around and asking our cat oh
so which cat food you read sir
and i was always perplexed by this so
how many cats did they actually ask um
there are about seven million cats in
the uk
how many have you got to ask in order to
be able to make such a claim
um so that again is about how much can i
throw away to really be justified in
making that claim and again mathematics
shows you that provided your um you know
five percent error either way we'll
we'll we'll take that but that still
isn't good enough because
well does that mean i've got to ask 95
of that 7 million no but we also do this
thing about i don't mind providing that
19 out of 20 times i will be getting
within five percent if you set that as
your bar of your shortcut you can get
away with about 250 cats
that's extraordinary i mean that's the
power of a shortcut in when you're
trying to navigate data suddenly i only
have to talk to 250 cats and i can know
pretty accurately you know 19 out of 20
times that will be within five percent
of what the actual value is it's pretty
amazing if you can talk to even one cat
to be honest but i i suppose you're
right
when one hears the word shortcut one of
the things that comes to your head is
being a bit sloppy or finding a quick
and dirty way of doing things but we
also know that mathematics is all about
this sort of this rigor and this
perfection this unbreakability
presumably when you use the word
shortcut you're not using it the way i
would like you know hanging a picture a
bit wonky on a nail on a wall exactly i
think this is a really important point
to stress that i'm after something which
still gets me um absolutely robustly to
a solution um i i don't want something
that's going to fall to par pieces a
little bit later so so this is a
distinction between shortcuts and
cutting corners but you know there are
times when it is about what is
unnecessary work that i don't need to do
um which is not really contributing to
understanding it's just creating a sort
of fog around here and i can take that
away so a part of it is about you know
what can i throw away and still i'm
going to get to to the solution
one of the rather extraordinary things
is that you know mathematics is very
good about talking about itself i mean
i've done a number file about girdles in
completeness theorem the power of
mathematical equations to talk about
itself mathematics is also able to
analyze itself and tell us when there
are no shortcuts so sometimes it's
important to know okay i can't get away
without doing a huge amount of work in
this particular case and so people have
probably heard of the travelling
salesman problem this is a challenge
about trying to visit every city in a
network in the shortest distance
possible and we now
think that there is no clever algorithm
to being able to solve this problem and
that's
one of the millennial problems one of
our greatest challenges is to prove
there are no shortcuts but that's
mathematics is very good at that in
showing why you cannot get away with
doing something quickly unlike euler's
very clever trick for koenigsberg you
don't have to navigate the whole of the
network to know something's possible or
impossible we think that in order to
find the shortest route the mathematics
will ultimately tell us there is no
shortcut
so this is um one called uh p versus np
so p actually for polynomial time those
are the kind of shortcut algorithms
those are the ones that when you run
them it doesn't matter how big they get
it still
finds you the solution quickly so the
other problems uh are ones where
actually the algorithms that we have
explode as the problem gets bigger
but they have this quality that if you
do find the solution it's almost like a
needle in a haystack you can't find it
but soon as you put your finger on it
wow you feel it so um so you can check
these things very quickly traveling
salesman problem is the classic one but
it's extraordinary how many other
problems um have this quality and again
here's a shortcut
amazing thing that we've discovered is
that all of these np problems if you
find a shortcut for one of them that
shortcut works for all of them that's
extraordinary so you know one shortcut
solves them all sort of kind of
tolkienesque
so that's also you know the power of
showing you know once you solve one
problem you solve loads of problems is
something mathematics loves
is this unique to mathematics
like does does it work for chemistry and
physics and biology or is that is it a
more of a mathy thing
i was quite intrigued to see
whether other professions actually had
their own shortcuts and and what sort of
things uh you know my life feels like
i'm trying always trying to find the
shortcut what what can you not get away
with uh shortcutting so so actually as
part of this project i've talked to a
lot of people in other professions for
example an international cellist can you
get away from i mean i i play the the
cello here you know i was quite
intrigued can i shortcut being able to
become a really great cellist playing
those bach suites so i talked to natalie
kleiner an international chalice and she
really explained actually well you're
having to physically change your body
you know as you practice you sort of uh
you're trying to get that muscle memory
so you almost don't have to think that
is ultimately a shortcut but that
requires a lot of time practicing so i
think anything that requires physically
changing your body like becoming an
international cellist or an athlete um
it's very difficult to to shortcut that
sort of physical um change so that was
interesting but there were other cases
uh for example i talked to brent
hoberman
who was the creator of lastminute.com
and he's done wonderful startups so it's
kind of intriguing what's your secret do
you have a shortcut to startups and he
said actually it's flying a little bit
close to the to the law you know you
want to break things a little bit to um
to make progress and actually that
resonated with me with another sort of
shortcut um which is the invention of
imaginary numbers we kind of broke a
rule there which you know squaring you
with square numbers there positive um
but what an amazing shortcut that
provided and you know there's a very
famous uh quote by um the french
mathematician about you know the
shortest path between two real things is
to go through the complex domain so this
is almost like a wormhole very often if
you can get complex numbers in there
radar for example you could do it just
with real numbers but it's a huge mess
as soon as you put it into complex
numbers the things becomes very
straightforward in fact i went to uh
visit uh
air traffic control and and the people
sitting there were saying you know we
wouldn't be able to land these planes in
time if we hadn't used the shortcut of
breaking that rule that every number is
positive so that was interesting there
are kind of resonances with other
professions that are similar to
to shortcuts that i've learned as a
professional mathematician i like that
it can't land planes without complex
numbers
i think we should solve the problem yes
go on then there's a shortcut to solve
this is there there is a shortcut
because if you try and solve this
problem it's quite nice because you can
try out uh various different numbers you
might try powers of two you might try
just experimenting see what it's doing i
mean essentially i wonder how many
weights you would have got down to with
that kind of experimental uh approach um
because it's quite surprising what you
can do is to get away with the following
weights one
three
nine and 27.
four weights i think a lot of people
will get down to five weights but i
actually see that you can go with with
four weights um is quite extraordinary
and why well you've probably noticed
those are powers of three
so um some of you might have tried
binary uh powers of two but you've got a
um an extra thing you can take advantage
of here which is these are balance
scales so you can put nothing on one
side one weight on one side or kind of
the negative that way on the other side
so in a way you're building a number we
want to get the numbers from 1 to 40
using either 0 1 or -1 so we're actually
working with ternary numbers
and so powers of three are going to be
able to to weight every number from one
to forty
if you enjoyed this video there's a fair
chance you'll enjoy marcus's new book
thinking better the art of the shortcut
it's already getting some good reviews
and i'm going to put a link to it in the
video description so you can get your
hands on a copy i'll also put a link to
marcus's recent appearance on the number
file podcast
so he just took 101
and times it by 50
and he got
5050. so this story was first
written about in an obituary by one of
carl gauss's friends